siamo sukuk io mi sun io ct weiss empire
ha ridotto 6 mar
siamo su con chiuque liquami che morire
consider it considerano questo è uno
spazio dove sei libero di considerare le
cose come preferisci
non c'è nessuno qua che ti ferma
nell'essere premuroso come preferisci
perché questo gioco consiste nell'essere
premurosi nei confronti del prossimo
dopo che poiché sai premuroso in una
situazione
muoviti nell'oggetto rosso nello schermo
numero uno siamo premurosi ci sono io
nella metro c'è una coppia di persone
che stanno insieme
si chiamano toghe e dell ami devo
spostare per farli sedere
ok se ne sono andati perché non mi
facevo sedere perfetto non è un c'è un
giusto sbagliato io devo fare le cose
giuste
avrei voluto tanto spostarmi non l'ho
fatto è un gioco che li stimola cli ge
da un boy ha semplicemente abbagliato
che disobbedendo questo è il gioco
questo è il gioco 5 euro in tokyo a
quello che deve passare non annoverato a
tokyo si fa spazio a tokyo si fa spazio
gli uccelli che volano in e io ci vado
contro teste di culo
mica mi metterò qua porca vacca di c.so
messo in un modo o nell'altro premuroso
ok together numero 6
questo è il gioco ora questo è il gioco
non ha un senso
ciao papà natale non esisti non esisti
sei un pezzente non dormire guardalo e
basta che tanto non esiste numero 7 che
se gioco che fa per me
posso però solo per prendere gli ordini
birra birra b e la birra birra e quello
che prendo io la mia mano
perfetto allora eccoli gli ordino la mia
mano in questo è quello che succede
quando tutti prendono la prima di base
gli ordini della birra sult e or.sa vera
anche se mi fa schifo purtroppo questa è
la mia vita di me a b c avvia a ricky
preferisco preferisco the papa 2020 se
faccio quest'ultimo strike verrai con me
l'ho preso mi ami adesso lurida scaltro
limaj li considero eight povero babbo
natale ho speso 5 euro per prendere per
il culo numerone 11
mister gay nave rivista che mi voci
questo sì cosa devo fare altre cose
questo il mio modo ricco di essere
premuroso nei confronti dei videogiochi
polis minchio varco demonio ma niente
basta tap tap
c'è un fantasma fotografano diventa
ricco farò ma l'ho avuto tra parlano
spaventarmi poi non era per niente
spaventato inoltra però numero 15 ei
ragazzi come funziona non ho visto
tutorial
e ora perfetto questo è come io allo
stadio sono l'anima della festa lui
limano i consiglierei non ho capito se
quella è una specie di giudizio finale
cos'è stiamo attraversando la strada
e io mi paro nei confronti delle
macchine che la pozzanghera arriva se no
questo quello che faccio io una volta mi
è successo sul serio è stata bellissima
chiedetelo al giorno andrea ragazzi di o
raddoppia mostrano di orion anzi ha
cambiato no che è arrivato un camion
eravamo proprio in giappone arrivato un
camion ha preso una pozzanghera cia
bagnati tutti gli ho dovuto fare colpo
d'ombrello che lo fa the next stop cose
che c'era anche mi devo scendere la
prossima fermata la prossima fermata e
lì erano bus terminal buttati coda
finestrino presenza neanche chiedere a
fermata buttati ai guadagni tempo fidati
una volta l'ho fatto cinque mesi
all'ospedale best friend and girlfriends
amico mio ti sta prendendo per il culo
ti sto salvando la vita non fatti sedere
anzi guarda fluttuo è let's dance bene
la ragazza si fa camminare a sinistra
perfetto però io sono tuo migliore amico
quindi cammino a destra
ecco amore seguimi 6 coraggio se riesci
più che altro perché sono cui 6 in volta
oggi un altro appuntamento
penso che adesso siamo una coppia di
fatto quindi andiamo non ho letto niente
chi pensa fisco la mente che rende
semplice le vere identità ok aprendo la
sua mano perchè mi ha fatto mi son ho
preso coraggio se andate a vedere un
film romantico cosa che faccio io mi
levo dalle palle e meraviglioso perché
comunque dove migliore amico è un
affluenza io sono entrato nel film this
chiedo scusa te com'è possibile che io
non riesco a limonare con la miracolati
pa e voi sì come cacchio è come si fa
uscire a friend son venute che fai con
la faccia beh così si fa ragazzi
considerare il bellissimo perché
riprende una delle scene gay vissuto
direttore sobria golfo nei dialoghi a
chi chi chi prendiamo per il range al
giallo boh io voglio fare power ranger
posto mi hanno preso no eccolo è
perfetto beh è stata un'ottima scelta a
colpiscimi ei mi hanno frenato tutte
vuoi essere il mio ragazzo no peccato
e io ci provo 35 d'auto marasma o degli
smile ancients questa è la mia ultima
palla chi l'ha tirata a testare sto
gioco e la storia comunque bellissimo 36
porca [ __ ] bagheera missile
cosa devo fare ci penso io
ci penso io come siccome facciamo avermi
non mi posso muovere non ho capito se a
volte devo cliccare perché la nota non
vi fa niente non ci si addormenta sul no
ma va tutto bene assaggia ecco mi sa che
non molli ci prendo questo così diventa
ancora più grosse indietro chi sei ma
chi sei
chi ti credi di essere volevi diventare
grosso come me ma chi sei
sono tornato felice di un tempo per un
secondo è stato poco premuroso ma che
figo guarda la costa ma che bella c'è un
ufo sono solo io ho al freddo ma mica
mia hai mai visto termine tornano
ibernato e tu farai la stessa fine di
san marino anadarko sigrade non è come
mi comporterei nel caso però 46 bene 66
come katy come bellissimo da leggere
fantastico giusto per niente disturbando
nessuno verona bellissimo guarda che bel
taglio di capelli già fatica ho mai
visto qua 47 ma cos'è ma da da fango ei
sono assetata puoi portarmi caffè gelli
i soldi non ce li ho un po di gelli vuoi
un po di budino gelli vuol dire gelatina
che cacchio te ne fai una volta lo prese
in giappone aveva una sete incredibile
mola racconto sul desktop bene visto che
lei mi prendo una magnate non sento più
una gnocca però vabbè
se ci si accontenta possiamo giorno io
me lo mangio io lo so non ho capito 50
tiro special one e spam non ho capito
niente consider non ho capito niente
ero eravamo io e gian io avevo una sete
aveva per dato aveva appena mangiato
rame piccante io avevo una sete che vi
giuro su quel che minchia volete stava
morendo vado alle macchinette non c'era
l'acqua perché la non c'è mai l'acqua
non c'è mai ci sono solo il ghetto re
del karate la la cosa più normale che mi
sembrava che ci fosse era del succo
d'uva una roba del genere era era era
viola detto la sala succo d'uva loeb è
un po mi disse tono era la cosa più
normale che c'era lì per farvi capire
come stavamo messi la prendo faccio così
già non esce niente era qua aspettami
controllare l'ora è di miggiano questa e
gelatina e gelatina in bottiglia giammai
ha fatto comunque ragazzi questa era
considera i kit non l'abbiamo
assolutamente finito l'ho fatto i primi
50 e già era abbastanza farò
assolutamente i prossimi spera così di
via almeno a cento perché meraviglioso
giuro mi sta divertendo tantissimo spero
di arrivare a 100
non ho capito se la traduzione essere
premurosi po no però semplicemente il
considerate fi quella cosa che in questo
in questa situazione tour normalmente
faresti e io ho fatto tutto l'opposto
vi siete nel canale schiaccia il tasto
mi piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo
allora seguito ai ragazzi
[Musica]